well those pipe bombs of course are one
of but many examples of attempted and
actual political violence we've seen
over the past few years one of the most
notable was an attempted massacre at a
congressional baseball practice in the
summer of 2017 Congressman Steve Scalise
of Louisiana was gravely wounded in that
shooting in response to the pipe bomb
mailings today he tweeted this quote
these attempted attacks that had been
made are beyond criminal they are acts
of pure terror violence and terror have
no place in our politics or anywhere
else in our society Congressman Steve
Scalise joins us and Congressman thanks
very much for coming on so what what was
your first reaction when you saw this
news today well Tucker it's it's anger
you know this isn't the way that we
should expect America to be turning I
mean you're seeing more and more of this
and clearly you've seen it on both sides
we all need to be calling it out
obviously we need to find out what
happened and the FBI is in the process
of doing it
I feel very confident that our law
enforcement officials are ultimately
gonna find out who did this and if it's
one or multiple people to bring them to
justice and do it as swiftly as possible
so the president condemned these acts
and was immediately rebuked by the
Democratic Party for condemning the acts
not quite enough what do you make of
that I thought that was a mistake on
their part to criticize the president
you know I think it was important that
the President did come out with his
statement the way did strongly I heard
silence a lot of times when Republicans
were under attack from Democrat leaders
we all should be calling this out when a
Republican or Democrat is under attack
first of all we don't even know who did
it we should be trying to find out who
did it but we should be criticizing the
act whether it's a Republican or
Democrat some people only criticize when
it's a Democrat under attack in the
media by the way was under attack too
and there's no place for that either how
do we deescalate
this things seem to be moving in a
direction that's ominous and so what do
our leaders need to do it's the extent
they have control to pull us back
I think the most important thing is to
get back to what made this country great
our founders didn't set up some kind of
system where everybody had to think the
same way in fact they challenged their
government and they wanted a system
where individual people can can speak
their views and even speak out against
their government and they put the First
Amendment ultimately in the Constitution
ensure that right but the difference is
we all have you know our disagreements
you should never make those personal and
you should never think that violence is
a way to settle our political
differences we settle them at the ballot
box we have an election in 13 days
that's where we settle our differences
violence is never an answer to to
somebody's political disagreement with
somebody else and so why is it
interesting point you make so you're
you're saying that people feel less free
to express their opinions now than they
have in previous generations and that's
part of the reason things are so
volatile well you know when somebody
tries to use threats or intimidation
it's like the schoolyard bully you know
if if they don't want to confront their
own demons they try to threaten you and
scare you away from just living your
everyday life and that's not who we are
as Americans you saw it after September
11th when our very way of life was under
attack by people who had a totally
different viewpoint of America and what
it stands for and we came together as a
country and we said we're not going to
back down we're not gonna change who we
are and we shouldn't do it here either
but we should be equally vigilant
Republican and Democrat no matter who is
under attack that it's wrong for whoever
did the attack let's find out the
details don't try to deflect blame and
try to blame somebody else who had
nothing to do with this let's actually
go after the people who did it that's
what we should do is in coming together
as Americans and again I mean it's not
about philosophy I'm a conservative
I have liberal friends I have
disagreements with them but I don't make
it personal and none of us should make
it personal we should want to find out
who did it let's get the facts don't go
trying to blame people that had nothing
to do with this let's all be focused on
coming together and finding out who did
it and bringing them to justice
coming from a man who is very close to
being murdered for his political beliefs
your words carry weight on that for sure
congressman thank you
always great to be with you Tucker